so joy reid on msnbc one of the worst
people on that channel
joy reid goes in and she says
that with and and what her guests say
more specifically
is this is about jewish supremacy
jewish supremacy is the main goal
of israel apartheid government and i
say the word apartheid because former
prime minister of israel
two of them hood ulmert uh security
services head of the mossad and many
others
use this word saying in absence of any
political solution
we will be entering apartheid we're
already in us
we're already living uh a project of
ethno religious exclusion and purity
this is what happened after years of
bibi netanyahu incitement
weaponization of religion and
weaponization of race
where it doesn't matter democracy for
even palestinians who live
inside what matter is their ethnicity
what matter is
the race the religion and it's it's
basically
this stage where the occupation is
metastasized
everywhere not only in gaza or in the
west bank or east jerusalem
but also inside uh israel so
what is the claim here because there's a
lot of these buzzwords these slogans
apartheid
ethnonationalism okay what is
what is this woman actually saying
jewish
supremacy we did a whole show last week
on on the dead rhetoric of the left what
is she saying
she's saying that israel is a jewish
state
yep that's true and they believe that
the jews should
have some special connection to the
state of israel yep duh that's a jewish
state
are you going to object if saudi arabia
is an arabian state
there aren't enough japanese people in
arabia uh-huh yeah i guess
you know what about japan for that
matter japan basically does not permit
immigration
are they going to complain because there
aren't enough nigerians in japan japan
is a japanese state
it well it's ethnonationalism yeah right
like most
states i guess yeah right israel is not
just an idea
you know i know it's become fashionable
in recent decades to say that
countries can be just an idea but that's
obviously reductive and absurd
countries are not countries can have a
creedal aspect no question about it
but countries also have a people and you
know the japan is a japanese
country right it has a connection to the
japanese people
it's the country for the japanese israel
is a jewish state that is what it is so
yes
is it are
palestinian arabs going to have a
different relationship to israel
than than jewish people will yeah yeah
of course
duh they they do have relatively
good access to uh the political system
right it's not as though muslims are
totally kicked out of the political
system in israel
far from it muslims participate quite
actively actually in the israeli
political system but it is to say there
is a special connection here for the
jews
just like there'd be a special
connection for the arabians in saudi
arabia and the japanese and japan it
makes perfect sense
why why we're not allowed to say that
now about countries is pretty strange
isn't it
pretty strange to me
oh no do not go anywhere before you
subscribe before you ring that bell very
very important
finally the vouchers of the world are
letting us unmuzzle ourselves
big tech wants to keep us digitally
muzzled so make sure you subscribe you
will be able
to get all of the notifications see on
the next one